[Music]
hello and welcome to this video which is
about the Sicilian defense and this time
we're going to examine other black moves
in this position besides the knight c6
and d6 they also have separate chapters
and this is the others category we have
to say that among those there is one
move that isn't particularly that is
particularly important this is to e6
this move is some amongst the most
popular yeah and it's a close
competition with d6 and 96
especially in recent years has become
more popular than ever before due to the
reason that black players tend to like
to avoid also the Bishop b5 lines as
after a six Bishop b5 makes a lot sense
we will get to this a little bit later
but we also have to check all the other
moves that black him has some and its
disposal this is a quite wide range of
moves from dubious to to quite quite
okay so we should go through it one by
one it is in fact yeah if it's in fact a
pretty easy concept now that we that we
are following here against all those
moves we are going to play c3 if
possible if not we need to do something
something else we will see how this
differentiates it's pretty easy to to
figure out so against ecigs we are going
to place you three and more about that
later against a6 we are also going to
place you three against g6 we play c3
against Knight f6 okay this is hanging
so we cannot place you three we have to
do something else there
and there is the move b6 very rare move
admittedly here c3 does not really work
out all that well because after Bishop
d7 our pawn is hanging and we don't want
to either play d3 or Bishop d3 so there
are two concrete cases where we don't go
c3 and other other cases either this
would be like 90 what percent of the of
the moves here more than 90 we play c3
the idea of c3 is always to build up
full Center of course with d4 and we
have to make a comparison for example if
we go a six year if we go see through
here it's a good thing to compare c3 on
move three to c3 here the so called
allow pin variation and this is not a
bad line of course and there are people
specializing in it the difference
between playing c3 on move to and only
doing it on move 3 after Black has
committed is that the most popular and I
think most testing continuations after
c3 they usually involve lights like for
example I want to show you one line in
particular that I'm quite fond of and
here for example black has an option to
play Bishop f4 f5 or Bishop g4 you can
place the Bishop Bishop outside of the
past I'd say here you can go is six
later well if you compare it to a
situation here
after c3 he will not be able to ever
develop the bishop easily after let's
say d5 pawn takes Queen takes so what we
are basically saying is we play c3 but
only after black has committed to some
move that is not necessarily very useful
in an entire LARPing system that does
not mean that black is in terrible shape
but it means that we get basically the
best possible out of the lab in setups
and some
that I'm not so comfortable we simply
avoid by not playing it on move - but
playing it on move three so I want to
look at a six yeah
at the final stage of this video it is
by far the most important move in terms
of frequency and in terms of quality so
let's get the smaller chapters that same
out of the way I'm going to start with a
six no particular order here a six is
the so called O'Kelly variation and this
is in fact not such a bad line it looks
very slow to play a six es an on
developing move but a six is a very
useful move actually in many open
sicilians so a try for y to open the
position up quickly with d4 ya sees
black having made a move that is often
quite useful in fact surprisingly enough
after a six there open Sicilian with d4
isn't any good this is one reason why is
six is popular in some way popular yeah
or let's say that is blacks motivation
behind doing it instead now after the
move e5 there is no night to b5 as we
are accustomed to in the in the smash
Nico for example it here black is in
fact in very good shape so d4 is not a
good move here we are not playing open
Sicilians anyway so it doesn't really
hurt us all that much in fact the main
museum that try to tackle a6 the hardest
artsy form for later maracas see point
or c3 it's the same case actually
against one sorry to g6 where C 4 and C
3 are the main moves
I recommend C 3 it's a very logical move
and connection to our concept here to
play C 3 on move 3 anyway so our idea is
to play d4 and ask black okay you played
a six what does that do in fact we are
oftentimes having just a position that
is similar to others that we will look
at later
and black has to spend a 6 which is kind
of semi useful at best probably here the
best move that black can play is the
most ecigs effect and this is of course
very similar to e6 on move to for
example here after d4 which is of course
what we're going to do black will go d5
that is the idea is 6 and this position
after it takes d5 we will examine later
right at the move order to e6 c3 black
content with the e pawn or with the
Queen both positions we will check you
later
riah this other move order a 6 is kind
of a again semi useful move IAM note
that in this particular situation white
could play e5 as well and this is an
advanced French on a sudden it's a
transposition with black having played
the move a 6 this is in fact a somewhat
rare line with a 6 but it is not that
bad surprisingly black has this idea
connected to it so if you play e5
this is not something special to get to
I mean of course if you like the
advanced French this is not part of this
repertoire against the French I
recommend something else if you like
this of course you can play e5 so this
is mostly a transposition but probably
the best option that black has of the
independent options the only move that
is worth looking at is probably d5 after
d5 we are going to take Queen takes and
replay deform so we open the position
against the yeah the early Queen moves
and of course you can compare that to
other variations in the alarp in a6 is
hmm yeah it is sometimes useful for
black to cover b5 but I think white is
generally happy here I hope you enjoyed
this preview of the kibbutzim
before repertoire you can get the full
course on chasuble calm which features
the move trainer that makes it easy and
simple to learn all the nice and
remember them and all the lights are
chosen with one thing in mind keep it
simple for you and make it difficult for
your opponent
[Music]
you